here in Monterey Bay off the coast of
California a National Geographic film
crew went after a story of transient
killer whales pursuing their prey but in
this case the story came to the film
crew a terrified sea lion
Bob's up next to the crew boat seeking
shelter from a pod of killer whales the
sea lion is so frightened it tries to
hurl itself into the boat
the whale pod is comprised entirely of
females and their calves only the
mothers get involved in the hunt the
12,000 pound killer whales thrashed the
600 pound sea lion with their tails
trying to beat it so badly
it will give up
the pot of killers working together in a
tight team force the sea lion under the
surface they'll hold it there until it
drowns and they end the hunt
with a victory week